peu
[Musique]
je
industrialiser et commercialiser depuis
la dernière guerre mondiale
les matières plastiques en
insensiblement envahi tous les domaines
de notre vie quotidienne
un tel point que notre habitation de
demain sera peut-être une bulle de
plastique ressemblant à un vaisseau
cosmique venu d'une autre planète
ces matériaux de synthèse sorti tout
droit des laboratoires des terriens ont
connu un formidable essor dans le
secteur particulier de l'emballage qui
représente aujourd'hui près de 25 % des
débouchés de la profession
[Musique]
beaucoup utilisé dans le domaine
alimentaire émis directement au contact
des denrées l'emballage plastique est
soupçonné d'être nocive un groupe
d'industriels répand savez vous que
notamment dans le domaine des idées et
des produits alimentaires
novartis en france est extrêmement dure
et que dans ce domaine les producteurs
souvent été obligé de mettre au point
des matériaux qui permettent la
compatibilité totale entre contenu
contenant le ministère de la santé et
donc la garantie du consommateur lorsque
l'emballage a rempli son office
il faut le détruire moyen le plus
radical et le feu hélas dans le domaine
rural les installations modernes
d'incinération font une apparition
encore bien timide oui parce qu'il
existe environ une dizaine de deux
usines en bretagne de ce type
cette usine est né depuis deux ans elle
était construite pour le compte du
syndicat intercommunal de la région doré
qui vont payer par le syndicat
intercommunal avec des subventions du
ministère de l'intérieur du ministère de
l'agriculture et du département
le soldat été payés directement par les
communes c'est une usine qui peut
traiter 130 tonnes d'ordures ménagères
par chez nous avons qu'un problème avec
les matières plastiques
on accuse encore les matières plastiques
de polluer l'atmosphère par incinération
dans un incinérateur
la plupart des matières plastiques ne
dégage à la combustion que de l'eau et
du gaz carbonique comme d'ailleurs les
matériaux combustibles naturel
le seul qui dégagent un gaz polluant et
le pvc polychlorure de vinyle qui ne
dégage pas de chlore de phosgène du gaz
de combat comme il a été dit et écrit
maintes et maintes fois mais qui dégage
en plus de l'eau et du gaz carbonique de
la cidob compte tenu d'une part de la
quantité de pvc contenu actuellement des
enduits de ménages et d'autre part de la
reconstitution des fours d'incinération
actuelle la quantité d'acide
chlorhydrique dégagé dans le pas là je
suis de cheminée est très faible en ce
sens que si nous prenons les normes les
plus sévères de rejet existant
actuellement dans le monde
nous sommes actuellement à moins d'un
cinquième du topic
ce taux limite sera vite atteint si
l'industrie des plastiques poursuit son
rythme de croissance qui consiste à
doubler sa production tous les cinq ans
ceci pour répondre à la demande des
consommateurs de plus en plus nombreux
et déchets eux suivent donc
parallèlement cette courbe ascendante
en france la production annuelle
d'ordures ménagères et de 11 millions de
tonnes dont un million de tonnes pour la
seule ville de paris soit une moyenne
nationale de 720 grammes par jour et par
habitant dans ce tonnage les déchets de
matières plastiques représentent
aujourd'hui 4%
c'est à dire quatre cent quarante mille
tonnes par an
[Musique]
la question est donc de savoir s'il faut
dès à présent condamné ou non
l'emballage plastique on assiste parfois
certain ostracisme contre des matériaux
par exemple parce que précisément n'a
pas regardé l'ensemble
or c'est bien c'est qu'il faut regarder
c'est effectivement tout ce qui se
produit depuis la fabrication à partir
de la matière première jusqu'à
l'élimination et y compris l'élimination
le fait de brûler et de matière
plastique par exemple combustible être
un gros avantage si vous le brûlé dans
un incinérateur avec récupération de
chaleur que vous donniez également un
chiffre de mémoire s'ils ont brûlés dans
des incinérateurs avec récupération de
chaleur
simplement le polyéthylène utilisait
pour les emballages séduit les
bouteilles de lait les films politiques
et habiterait aux fruits et légumes etc
et bien en brouille dans un incinérateur
on obtiendrait comme pouvoir calorifique
l'équivalent de 250 mille tonnes de
pétrole deux cent cinquante mille tonnes
de pétrole je dis bien de pétrole épuré
99 95 % puisque le polyéthylène
pratiquement c'est un produit composé
uniquement de carbone et d'hydrogène
je pense que même là aussi nous faisons
une économie appréciable pour
l'environnement parce que nous avons
économisé des calories et nous avons
économisé une certaine pollution de
l'atmosphère que l'on aurait avec une
vision du fuel normal de fioul
domestique ou du fioul industriel un
autre à ibiza on peut aussi que
peut-être ils m'ont frappée il sait que
ces deux cent cinquante mille tonnes de
fioul ça présente vingt cinq mille
camions citernes de 10 tonnes est tout
de même ses problèmes l'encombrement des
routes sont pas non plus négligeable à
notre époque
[Musique]
la pollution par les matières plastiques
est avant tout une pollution visuelle
car lorsque le déchet n'est pas incinéré
comme en ville il est abandonné
n'apporte en cela l'exemple de l'île de
sein est significatif parce que cette il
représente le type même d'une communauté
fermée qui doit obligatoirement éliminé
sur place la totalité de ces déchets
c'est un impératif de survie
en
[Musique]
autrefois tout transport de liquides 20
vinaigre huile essence même pétrole se
faisait en bouteilles de verres et des
bouteilles de verre été réacheminés sur
le continent par les transports donc il
y avait des pots moment tone et des
bouteilles sur l'île mais il n'y avait
pas dans les greffes de déchets à
pouvoir s'agglomérer actuellement nous
recevons le lait l'eau minérale le vin
enfin il ya énormément de denrées qui
circulent en emballages plastiques
nous avons d'abord une consommation
intérieure donc un rejet de déchets de
par la population ils viennent ensuite
nous avons un apport maritime de déchets
sous les plastiques les peaux boîtes de
conserves flottant au gré des flots des
vents il arrive sur la cote
la partie plastique et quand même
recueilli peut-être à 70 80 60 90 il se
détruit pas à l'eau il s'ag l'omert dans
certains coins il brûle mais ce n'est
pas la solution étant donné qu'ils
brûlent en polluants si nous nettoyons
une partie de l'île nous devenons paul
heures quant à la destruction étant
donné qu'actuellement nous n'avons pas
d'installation complète la ferme
tout vient en plastique
[Musique]
la pollution due aux plastiques gagne
toute la france comme les rivages la
campagne est dégradée multiplication des
rebuts de plastique devient notre
hantise qui est responsable de cette
pollution
celui qui fabrique le matériau de base
celui qui produit l'emballage
écoutez nous en sommes que nous
entendons tous très attristés
mais est-ce que vous pensez que si vous
trouvez un vieux matelas ou un vieux
servier dans la nature vous considérez
que le producteur de sommiers
responsable est ce que quand vous voyez
une vieille voiture rouillé sur la voie
publique et abandonnez vous dit tiens
c'est le constructeur est responsable de
ses productions
on vous reproche de faire un matériau
qui n'est pas biodégradable c'est à dire
que la nature nous n'avale pas digère
pas facilement pourquoi il était le sien
il faut bien que nous avons mis beaucoup
de temps à étudier des matériaux qui ne
se dégrade pas c'est un bel acte avec
regret qu'il faut qu'ils soient de plus
en plus protecteurs de plus en plus
résistants
de plus en plus léger et gabor et la
matière plastique est intervenu pour
participer à ce service qui consiste à
apporter aux consommateurs les matières
de plus en plus modernes pour lui
permettre de protéger les habitants de
protéger les autres produits qui font de
bien être de cheap et c'est pour cela
nous avons étudié les matières restent
mais non pas défaut aux autres
résistants
le véritable problème des plastiques se
posera d'une façon catégorique ici 10 à
15 ans la production mondiale des
matières plastiques se situer à 1
million de tonnes
il y a vingt ans nous en sommes
aujourd'hui à près de 35 millions de
tonnes
et si ce développement se poursuit d'une
façon constante la production avoisinera
un milliard de tonnes pour la seule
année 2000
[Musique]
oh
le carreau moins de cette production
sera consacrée à l'emballage donc à un
produit de courte durée de vie destinée
à être jeu
[Musique]
et
comment se débarrasser aujourd'hui des
déchets en plastique jetés
inconsidérément dans la nature qui se
refuse quant à elle à recycler un
matériau qu'elle n'a pas enfanté
le ministère de l'environnement a chargé
monsieur jacques l'option d'une étude
sur la question
nous lui avons proposé nous une solution
supprimer complètement l'emballage en
plastique
une solution qui a l'air d'être radical
en fait je crois qu'elle est très fausse
parce qu'il faut tout de même pas
oublier que si le plastique c'est
développer un tel taux de croissance
dans le passé c'est parce que les
consommateurs veulent du plastique les
commodités offertes en plastique sont
considérables et si vous adoptiez une
telle solution vous auriez affaire à une
émeute de consommateurs très rapidement
et pourtant
devant l'accroissement de la population
du globe qui aura doublé en l'an 2000
c'est à dire dans moins de 30 ans et
d'autre part devant l'ascension
vertigineuse du volume des déchets du
consommateur il vient d'être déposée sur
le bureau du président nixon aux états
unis un projet de loi qui tendrait à
interdire l'emballage perdu de toute
nature pour 95 % des emballages en
plastique sont de type perdu
est il encore possible aujourd'hui
d'éviter cette solution draconiennes et
peut-on espérer trouver un remède pour
endiguer la marée des déchets de
plastique qui semblent menacer notre
environnement de demain si on fait un
tour de piste globale de toutes les
solutions qu'on peut envisager ou qui
sont actuellement pratiqués et ont
mentionné les plus désagréables
peut-être même en commençant par elle il
faut citer ce qu'on appelle des ordures
sauvage qui était un mode particulier et
très favorable de se débarrasser de
quelque chose c'est de le mettre
n'importe où c'est vrai pour le
plastique c'est vrai pour tout le reste
aussi pour tous les autres matériaux
ça passe probablement par une éducation
intensif que des individus un deuxième
moyen qui est pratiqué d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est pas des charges
publiques classiques poules dindes
entièrement satisfaction parce qu' elle
n'est pas très propre
il ya certes un risque d' incendies de
différents matériaux qui se contrôle sur
ces décharges publiques annonce semble
de plus en plus de créer des décharges
contrôlées qui sont une amélioration des
précédentes et qui consiste à étaler des
couches de terre au dessus des couches
d'ordures encore une fois les ordures
sont de toutes nature y est pas du
plastique là dedans c'est un des moyens
de résoudre la question s'est passé par
le plus glorieux bien entendu on trouve
l'incinération qui est un moyen assez
radical puisqu'il consiste à brûler
systématiquement tout ce qui est
considéré comme étant un déchet il faut
bien voir que les vapeurs toxiques en
l'occurrence le gaz chlorhydrique qui
s'échappe après après incinération du
pvc représente relativement peu de chose
comparé par exemple aux émanations des
automobiles pour prendre un exemple un
ordre de grandeur
il ne faut pas mettre trop l'accent là
dessus pour l'instant
ceci dit l'incinération est un moyen
il y en a peut-être d'autres mais qui ne
sont pas mûrs technologiquement et qui
nécessiterait de la recherche
je pense par exemple à la pyrolyse
suivent les le processus est de casser
par la chaleur les molécules chimiques
pour aboutir à des molécules chimiques
plus petites plus simples dont on peut
se servir à nouveau pour une nouvelle
synthèse chimique ou encore pour pour
les brûlés à leur tour puisque certains
pensent qu'on peut par ces procédés
générer des fuels pour compléter ce
tableau il faut tout de même mentionner
le recyclage qui est une technique
toujours très tentante que ce soit pour
les matériaux à base de résines
plastiques ou pour tous les autres le
recyclage est un faux problème parce que
l'on garde toujours le plastique on le
transforme mais il est toujours là il
m'a toujours là mais le plastique n'est
pas nuisible en lui même il est nuisible
en tant que déchet donc si vous pouviez
utiliser un déchets de plastique c'est à
dire quelque chose qui a été rejetée par
un consommateur pour en faire un objet à
très longue durée de vie imaginez que
vous puissiez mélanger des déchets de
plastique royer recolorer avec du sable
ou du gypse et tous fassiez les allées
de jardin avec qui ressemblerait soit du
marbre soin de leurs doigts ça existe a
déjà été tentée vous fait un sort à
votre péché de plastique et voulu
l'utiliser en un bien qui a une raison
d'être économique faut bien voir qu'on
ne peut pas aller très loin dans la
technique du recyclage on ne peut pas
résoudre la totalité du problème pour
l'instant il faut mentionner que le
recyclage est pratiqué dans les usines
et systématiquement puisque toutes les
chutes de fabrication très généralement
font l'objet d'un recyclage
le problème serait de pratiquer le
recyclage à partir des déchets du
consommateur et cela pose tous série
problème très compliqué parce qu'il
faudrait d'abord isoler les objets en
plastique des autres dans les ordures
ménagères donc peut-être éduquer le
consommateur à les séparer lui même
avant de jeter tous ces déchets ce qui
n'est pas très facile de faire parce que
c'est une gêne supplémentaire a demandé
aux gens monsieur l'option après cette
étude
êtes vous optimiste ou pessimiste moi
j'ai tendance à être assez optimiste
même même relativement très optimiste
qui me semble que le problème du
plastique des plastiques n'est pas un
problème dramatique comparé à d'autres
parce que les gens sont parfaitement
conscients nous ne sommes qu'au début de
l'ère du plastique et les gens ont tout
de suite vu les problèmes qu'ils avaient
poussés
[Musique]